enfin 3
elle s'applique compte sur ses doigts
à 21 ans floriane peine sur des devoirs
de niveau élémentaire mais elle y met
tout son coeur sous le regard protecteur
de sa maman elle a toujours été là pour
moi elle moments difficiles comme les
opéras comme l'ail opération une maman
omniprésent parce qu'il ne peut en être
autrement
la faute à un médicament dont elle ne
soupçonnait pas la dangerosité
je prenais le des pâquis pendant ma
grossesse et ce qui fait que le foetus a
été touché et
donc elle est née avec plusieurs
malformations
donc il ya des choses qui se sont un
petit peu arrangé en a d'autres qui se
sont des cadets en grandissant des
malformations dont l'état était reconnu
pour partie responsable pour la première
fois dans trois dossiers similaires à
celui de floriane en revanche les
troubles neurodéveloppementaux n'ouvrira
droits à indemnisation que pour les
victimes nées après 2004 lorsque le lien
entre des paquin et autisme aurait été
officiellement reconnu ces troubles ont
pourtant été signalé depuis 1984 une
aberration pour florence dont la fille
est née en 98 on comprend pas pourquoi
ils ont pas appris cette date là on
arrêter mais qu'ils ont pris 2004 parce
que faut savoir ça fait quand même un
peu plus 80 % d'enfants qui seraient pas
indemnisés
c'est énorme lorsque floriane est né
avec toutes ses séquelles les médecins
l'ont mis sur le compte de la faute à
pas de chance
une mauvaise fortune dont serait victime
16000 à 30 mille enfants un lourd bilan
que devra tôt ou tard affronter le
laboratoire sanofi mise en examen pour
tromperie aggravée et blessures
involontaires